Here's another principle by Robert Martin,
called the Interface Segregation Principle. Robert Martin developed this,
principle, which suggests that clients depend on an interface to
a part of a large class's features rather than directly on the large class.
Note the relationship of this principle to role-based design that we discussed
earlier in the course. In role based design, classes are synthesised from
interfaces each of which reflect a role that objects of that class might play.
The implication of this principle, like that of role based design,
is that class interfaces should be broken into small pieces,
each corresponding to a single use case.